this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
we've made a total of 14 videos covering
the 2020 5k
imac spanning everything from our
buyer's guide to various comparison
videos
trying to figure out the value of this
year's imac
and we think we're finally ready to
close the case and wrap
everything up in this review the main
goal i want to reach in this review is
to help you make an informed decision
on whether you should actually buy this
imac or skip it
and the answer changes based on what you
personally care about
so let's dig deep into various topics
like apple switching to their own custom
silicon chips
why it makes sense for some people to
just buy this intel imac right now
which upgrades are actually worth it for
certain workflows
and i'm gonna talk about my very
important discovery
about how to configure your ram
correctly for the most performance
so let's get started we purchased and
tested two different models of the imac
the high-end base model with the a core
cpu and the 5500 xt gpu
and we also got a top-end model with the
10 core cpu
and the best 5700 xt graphics card
option
when we first started comparing the 2020
imac to other machines
like the imac pro we quickly realized
that for most people
the imac is definitely a better choice
especially now that it comes with
a faster sd card slot a 1080p webcam
with upgraded microphones
and an option for 10 gigabit ethernet
which all used to be huge reasons
to choose the imac pro instead there was
also the t2 chip which helped the imac
pro do a great job
with a lot of common video editing tasks
and now
the 2020 imac has the same t2 chip
but on top of that it also gets a couple
of bonuses
like quick sync and coding support and
navi graphics hardware accelerators
one of the major downsides of last
year's 5k imac
was that even the expensive vega 48
graphics card
was still the major limitation for a lot
of tasks
and now the imac can be configured with
the 5700 xd
graphics card which greatly improves
graphics performance
this new card gave us almost 50 percent
better fps
in the unigine heaven gaming benchmark
about 50 percent higher
timeline fps for playing back red raw ak
video
and we also got perfect 60 fps for
playing back canon c200 raw
but the biggest difference is thanks to
apple's t2 chip
specifically for encoding hevc footage
now being over twice as fast as before
we then compared these new imacs to the
16-inch macbook pro
and this year we're finally recommending
the imac over the macbook pro
because it's now a much better bang for
the buck especially since it gets a much
better cooling system
due to the much larger size we finished
off our comparisons
pitting the 10 core imac against our 15
000
mac pro which has the 12 core cpu with
vega 2 graphics and a massive 192 gigs
of 6 channel ram and we found some very
interesting results
for a lot of common tasks like for video
editing
there really wasn't that big of a
difference at least when comparing the
price points of each mac
the hevc stabilization test ended up
being much faster on the new imac
because it's also utilizing the
integrated graphics chip
that's in the processor which the mac
pro
doesn't have we also exported our 12
minute
how much ram for mac and 2020 video
which is packed with many of the effects
that we use on a daily basis
making it just about the most real world
test
in terms of what we edit every day and
the mac pro finished exporting it
only 9 seconds faster and that's because
the encoding of this type of footage
is taken care of by the t2 chip which is
identical
on both of those macs by far the biggest
advantage for the mac pro
was for processor heavy tasks that
depend on ram
and stable processor performance the mac
pro has a massive advantage of having
192 gigs
of 6 channel ecc ram compared to only 64
gigs
of dual channel ram on the imac so this
led to almost
triple the performance and puget bench
for photoshop
and finishing almost twice as fast in
our 500 raw 42 megapixel lightroom
export test
and being able to build one-to-one
previews almost
twice as fast as well and then thanks to
the more reliable server grade
xeon chip with 12 cores the mac pro was
able to handle almost 100 more tracks in
logic pro 10
for music production and the programming
results were very impressive
in xcode as well but the truth is that
not very many people
can justify the fifteen thousand dollar
price tag
of the mac pro to take advantage of
those gains
and even though it's upgradable the
future is still
in apple silicon which will likely
require you to sell
the intel mac pro for an arm based
silicon model
down the road and for the price tag of 3
200
for the imac the performance is actually
really good
especially compared to the previous
imacs and basically every other mac you
can get right now
however the most important piece of info
that we discovered
is that the 10 core i9 upgrade for 400
isn't worth it even for those who only
want to use it for processor heavy
workloads
but before i get into the results
between those two cpus
i want to touch on the absolute best way
to configure your ram
for maximum performance so i ran a few
tests that are very memory sensitive
while using various ram configurations
but before we get into those results
i want to give a huge shout out to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
if you've been thinking about making
your own website squarespace is
literally the best way to go i built an
engaging website for my wife's cleaning
business with literally no web making
experience
you just choose a template customize
blocks of text and images
and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple
affordable and it's been running
flawlessly for almost two years
bringing in new clients thanks to its
built-in seo tools
so whether you're making a website for a
small business or for literally
anything else go to squarespace.com for
a free trial
and use our custom link below when
you're ready to launch to save 10
on your first purchase of a website or
domain back to the imac
we quickly found out that if you want 64
gigabytes of ram
you get better performance by having
four sticks
instead of two as geek mesh 5 jumped to
over 10 000
points and our lightroom classic export
finished a minute and 40 seconds faster
as well
which we didn't expect now there's also
the question of mixing
apple's factory 8 gigs of ram with let's
say
32 gigs of aftermarket ram for a total
of 40 gigabytes
this instantly resulted in memory speed
dropping
to 2133 megahertz which in turn
dropped multi-core performance down to
around
9 300 points as well as slowing down our
lightroom classic export
to over 29 minutes we then moved the ram
sticks around so that the two 16 gig
sticks were at the top
and the two 4 gig sticks were at the
bottom as some suggested to do
and that did finally get the ram back to
running at the full
26 67 megahertz speed but then
multi-core performance
tanked down to 7 700 points
and our lightroom export test took a
massive
42 minutes and 30 seconds we discovered
that by moving the aftermarket ram
sticks next to each other
it actually forced the ram into single
channel mode
so there are three lessons we can learn
from these tests
if you know you won't be upgrading to
more ram down the line
just fill all four ram slots to maximize
performance
but be careful not to mix and match
different ram
sizes like keeping the factory ram
because it can actually slow
down performance and whatever you do do
not configure your ram
in single channel mode now with that
let's get into why the 10 core i9 cpu
upgrade
isn't worth the extra 400 based on all
of our testing
we quickly figured out that the 10 core
processor wasn't worth the price
for a lot of tests that we ran even the
ones that greatly rely on processor
performance
we tested photoshop in lightroom classic
photo editing
and in both of those tests the 10 core
wasn't worth it we then tested logic pro
10 music production
and the 10 core barely helped at all
only handling
6 more tracks before overloading the
system
xcode programming performance barely
improved either
only saving 12 seconds compared to the a
core i7
while building our maxtec xcode project
and then for video editing in final cut
pro 10
we quickly realized that the 10 core was
doing nothing for performance
it was simply the 500 graphics upgrade
that led to any performance gains
and we even found out that in some tests
that were processor dependent
the 8 core was actually slightly faster
because it runs at faster clock speeds
under load now i do want to mention that
it's not that the 10 core i9 is
underwhelming
in fact it's faster than a mac pro's 12
core z on cpu
in terms of the reliable cinebench r20
stress test
it's just that this year's base 8 core
i7
is extremely fast over 20
faster than last year's 8 core i9 which
you had to pay
an extra 400 for so how in the world is
that possible
well apple seems to be power limiting
the i9s
but not the i7s and to prove that
the 2028 core hits 161 watts under load
compared to 120 watts last year
and the 10 core can use up to 151 watts
still less than this year's 8 core so
please
don't waste your money and just stick to
the i7
which makes the 2020 imac an incredible
value
as it provides 10 core i9 performance
for the price
of last year's 6 core i5 and to make
things even better
not everyone needs the 500 5700 xt
graphics which in turn brings the price
down even more
from thirty two hundred dollars for the
top end spec all the way down
to twenty three hundred dollars so let
me explain why not everybody needs the
better graphics
for starters graphics does nothing for
processor heavy tasks
like photo editing programming and music
production
and for video editing with common 4k
formats
the 5500xt has the exact same hardware
decoders and encoders
as the highest end graphics and it also
has
enough raw power for most people that
are editing h.264
and hevc footage the 500 5700
xt was really only worth it for three
things that we tested
video editing with raw codecs like c200
and red raw footage 3d graphics
rendering
and gaming where it was almost 50
percent faster
so for those tasks the 500 upgrade can
actually be worth the price
unlike the 10 core cpu upgrade but if
you're not doing any of that
then the 2300 imac model with the 8 core
cpu
and the 5500 xt graphics gives you the
most bang for the buck
we've ever seen in any imac in fact
this year we've decided to keep this
exact model
for our daily video editing needs
instead of the top-end model
that we usually keep because that 2300
imac is only slightly slower than
the 10 core 5700xt model
while being a massive 900 cheaper
and that says a lot so now that we know
all of that
there's only one question that remains
do you buy
this intel imac or do you wait for the
future apple silicon models
well once again i think the answer
really depends on what you personally
care about
there are some people that are upset
with apple for not redesigning the imac
for the past eight years
and there are others who don't really
care the latter are more focused on the
performance
the feature set and getting their work
done faster
more reliably and more conveniently and
for those kinds of people
this new imac is great offering
excellent performance at a much better
value than we've seen
in years and now apple has finally
packed in some long-awaited features
like a faster sd card slot 10 gigabit
ethernet for only a hundred dollars more
a 1080p webcam with better microphones
ssds at the base price
and hardware accelerators with apple's
c2 chip
and amd's navi graphics that make a huge
impact on real world performance so if
you care about those things
you can't really go wrong by buying the
2020 imac
the biggest issue with the future apple
silicon models
is that we have no way of knowing how
well third-party apps will run on them
due to using the new arm based
architecture
and we don't really know how long it
could take for those apps to get fully
optimized
we already know that running the full
version of windows using bootcamp
is not happening on apple silicon so
this
question is a no-brainer for those who
need that functionality
and on top of that we don't really know
when those apple silicon imacs will get
released
most leaks and rumors are pointing to
the first arm-based imac
getting released early next year but
that's only for the 24-inch model
which isn't focused on high performance
the larger model which will replace
the 27-inch intel imac is actually
rumored to be coming in the second half
of 2021
and that's a long time to wait for those
who really need a
fast and value-packed imac right now
which is quite literally
why we bought this intel imac but in
defense of apple silicon
i'm very confident in a few different
things apple's chips are gonna run using
less power
they'll run cooler and the fan noise
will be going down and in terms of
performance
i'm extremely confident that all of
apple's native apps like final cut and
xcode
are going to run extremely fast because
apple has been optimizing them
for their custom silicon for a long time
now
and apple also mentioned that they've
been working with microsoft and adobe
to get all of their apps running
natively on apple silicon
as well so that's pretty reassuring for
people who use
those apps a lot and i have a feeling
that apple is going to be packing their
chips with hardware accelerators
which will greatly improve performance
without requiring a lot of raw power
just like we saw in the video editing
results between the 5500
xt and the 5700 xt graphics cards
so my honest advice to all of you guys
is that if you don't care about boot
camp
if you don't rely on third-party apps
and if your current computer will be
just fine for another year
then i would definitely recommend
waiting for apple silicon max
but if you don't really care for the
apple silicon transition or if you doubt
the performance
matching up to the current intel models
then just go for this 2020 imac
and enjoy reliable performance right now
and you can eventually switch to an
apple silicon mac
a couple of years down the road when
everything has been optimized
and all of the apps that you use are
confirmed to be working well
on the new custom apple chips but if we
disregard
all of that and just look at the 2025k
imac for what it is
it's a fantastic machine with much
better value and way more performance
than ever before while also fixing most
of our previous complaints
at the same time so there you guys have
it if this review was helpful
go ahead and tap the like button below
and click the circle above to subscribe
and you can definitely check out our
2020 imac playlist
right over there to see all of our
comparison videos and definitely check
out our apple product merch
down in our merch shelf below thanks for
watching and we'll see you
in the next video
[Music]